WHAT'S UP, Y'ALL?
IT'S TIME TO PLAY A GAME.
WE'RE GOING TO PLAY A GAME
CALLED QUESTLOVE'S OSCAR TRIVIA.
AND HERE TO HELP US IS
MY BOY, LIL REL.
>> ALRIGHT WHAT'S UP EVERYBODY?
I'M TALKING TO EVERYBODY
HOW Y'ALL DOING? YOU GOOD?
EVERYBODY GOOD?
ALRIGHT, FIRST OF ALL,
CONGRATULATIONS TO H.E.R.
AND THE "JUDAS AND THE
BLACK MESSIAH" FAMILY.
I'M SO HAPPY FOR 'EM AND DANIEL,
BUT LOOK, THAT'S NOT
ABOUT THAT RIGHT NOW. WE
ABOUT TO PLAY A GAME, OKAY?
QUEST IS GOING TO PLAY A SONG
FROM A MOVIE
AND WE GONNA TRY TO FIGURE
OUT IF IT WAS AN OSCAR
NOMINEE, AN OSCAR WINNER,
OR NONE OF THE ABOVE, MMKAY?
I'M GONNA ASK ONE OF YA, I'M GONNA
FIGURE OUT WHO I'M GONNA TALK TO
'CAUSE IT'S GONNA BE A FUN GAME.
DON'T LOOK NERVOUS.
I CAN SEE THAT NOBODY TALK TO YA'LL
IN A WHILE, Y'ALL OKAY?
EVERYBODY LIKE --
SO, IMMA FIND SOMEBODY--
I GOTTA FIND SOMEBODY WHO'S
INTO MUSIC THOUGH, LEMME SEE
AH SEE, I GOT TO GO TO
MY GIRL OVER HERE.
HEY, ANDRA DAY.
YOU WANT TO PLAY THIS
GAME WITH ME?
YOU READY FOR THIS?
GIVE HER A MICROPHONE
THAT'S THE MIC HAND,
'CAUSE WE CAN'T SHARE
MICS. YEAH, OKAY.
HERE WE GO.
YOU READY?
>> OKAY, I'M READY.
>> QUESTLOVE, PLAY THE SONG.
[ MUSIC PLAYS ]
>> OKAY.
YOU TRYING TO HARMONIZE?
>> NAH, NAH, YOU HEARD THAT,
IT SOUND GOOD.
SO I'M GONNA ASK YOU THIS:
IS THIS AN OSCAR WINNER OR JUST
AN OSCAR NOMINEE, OR NONE
OF THE ABOVE?
>> UH, I MEAN, IT'S A BRILLIANT
SONG. IT PROBABLY WASN'T EVEN --
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IT IS, RIGHT? BECAUSE IT
WASN'T NOMINATED, ACTUALLY.
>> DING.
>> NO. THE SCORE WON THE AWARD,
BUT NONE OF THE SONGS FROM
THE SCORE GOT NOMINATED,
AIN'T THAT CRAZY?
>> THAT SOUNDS ABOUT
RIGHT. HERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
THAT'S GONNA COST YA'LL, ABC,
BUT IT HAPPENED.
WE'RE IN A TRAIN STATION. YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR.
ALRIGHT. LET ME SEE IF I CAN
FIND SOMEBODY ELSE TO PLAY
THIS GAME WITH. OKAY,
I GOTTA GO TO MY BOY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
SEE NOW I NEED YOU TO SAVE ME, NOW.
'CAUSE THAT WAS CRAZY OVER THERE.
CAUSE NOW IT IS FOR ME TO SAVE YOU.
NOW EVERYBODY KNOW I SAVED
THIS BROTHER.
>> YEAH, YOU DID, YOU DID.
>> I SAVED YOU.
>> YOU GOT ME OUTTA THAT HOUSE
>> I STOLE A CAR FROM MY JOB,
DROVE IT TO THE WOODS
AND PICKED YOU UP AND
WE DROVE OFF.
>> YES WE DID, INTO THE SUNSET.
>> IT'D NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> NEVER. I WILL NEVER GET CAUGHT
WITH A WOMAN LIKE THAT AGAIN.
>> ALRIGHT, OKAY, HERE WE GO,
BROTHER. YOU READY FOR THIS?
>> YEAH.
>> ALSO, YOU WON AN OSCAR
TONIGHT, BRO.
>> I KNOW IT'S CRAZY, RIGHT?
>> IT'S GONNA BE CRAZY TONIGHT.
>> NOT TONIGHT, BRO,
NOT TONIGHT.
>> ALRIGHT, HERE WE GO.
QUEST, PLAY THE SONG.
>> ALRIGHT.
[ MUSIC PLAYS ]
>> OH, SHE SAID YOU TOO YOUNG
TO KNOW.
>> GLENN TOLD ME I WAS
TOO YOUNG.
SHE'S JUST -- SHE PUT ME
IN HER POCKET REAL QUICK,
"YOU'RE TOO YOUNG.
SIT DOWN."
>> OSCAR WINNER, OSCAR NOMINEE,
OR NONE OF THE ABOVE?
>> NOMINEE.
>> A NOMINEE?
>> NO, THEY WON. YEAH, THEY
WON AN OSCAR.
DONNA SUMMER WON.
>> OH, MAN, I DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THAT.
>> SHE WAS RIGHT. YOU'RE TOO
YOUNG. YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
"THE LAST DANCE" IS AN OSCAR
WINNING SONG.
DONNA SUMMER DID THAT.
YA'LL GIVE IT UP FOR
DONNA SUMMER,
LEGENDARY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> MAN, THEY GOT DONNA SUMMER.
THEY GOT DONNA SUMMER.
>> ALRIGHT, I'M DONE WITH YOU BRO.
SOMEBODY COME GET HIS MIC.
GET HIS MIC, CAUSE HE WAS WRONG.
DONNA SUMMER, BRO.
YOU IN THE SUNKEN PLACE
AGAIN, MAN.
ALRIGHT, YOU KNOW WHO
IMMA GO TO?
I'M GOING TO GLENN CLOSE
ON THIS ONE.
THE ICON.
ARE YOU READY FOR THIS?
>> YEAH.
>> 'CAUSE YOU TOLD HIM
HE WAS TOO YOUNG FOR
THE DONNA SUMMER SONG.
>> WELL, HE WAS.
>> IMMA CHALLENGE-- I THINK
WE GOT SOMETHING, I DON'T KNOW
QUESTLOVE, JUST PLAY IT.
LET ME SEE.
>> HERE WE GO.
[ MUSIC PLAYS ]
>> OKAY, STOP, STOP.
THAT'S NOT FAIR TO GLENN CLOSE.
SHE DON'T KNOW NOTHING ABOUT --
>> WAIT A SECOND. WAIT A SECOND,
I KNOW -- THAT'S "DA BUTT."
YEAH, IT'S "DA BUTT," I KNOW THAT.
"DA BUTT" WAS, WAIT A SECOND,
IT WAS A CLASSIC SONG BY
THE GREAT WASHINGTON D.C.
GO-GO BAND E.U.
SO, YEAH, SHOUT OUTS TO SUGAR BEAR
AND THE BACKYARD BAND
AND THE WHOLE DMV.
SO ANYWAY, SO, WAIT, NO, I REMEMBER
THIS. SO, SPIKE LEE HAD IT WRITTEN FOR
HIS BRILLIANT MOVIE "SCHOOL DAZE”
AND, UM, MY FRIENDS AT THE OSCARS
MISSED IT AND IT WASN'T NOMINATED
SO IT COULDN'T HAVE WON.
WHICH I THINK IS A --
>> I WASN'T EXPECTING THAT AT
ALL, THAT YOU KNEW "DA BUTT."
IT'S DOPE AND UNCOMFORTABLE
AT THE SAME TIME THAT YOU --
BUT-- BUT, DO YOU KNOW THE
DANCE, THOUGH?
DO YOU KNOW HOW TO DO "DA BUTT"?
QUEST, TURN IT UP.
C'MON, LET'S SEE IT.
LET ME SEE YOU DO DO "DA BUTT."
LET'S SEE IT!
OHHHHH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
OH MY GOD, THAT WAS --
SHE DID THE WHOLE BUTT
AT THE OSCARS.
THIS IS THE BLACKEST OSCARS
OF ALL TIME, YA'LL.
GLENN CLOSE JUST DID
DA BUTT AT THE OSCARS.
QUESTLOVE, PLAY "DA BUTT" TO THE
BREAK. GO AHEAD.
LET'S GET OUTTA HERE.
>> ALRIGHT, WE'RE GONNA DO THAT.
>> UP NEXT, ANGELA BASSETT.
AND I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SAY
ANYTHING MORE.
JUST ANGELA BASSETT.
OH, AND THIS IS THE
OSCARS ON ABC.